tout est avec nous pour en parler
danielle simonnet oratrice la france
insoumise vous êtes également danielle
simonnet conseillère elle fit à la
mairie de paris bonsoir et merci ça avec
vous ce soir on dirait qu'un par skype
avec 112 et vice-président l ère du
département de l'essonne bonsoir
alexandre tous et merci choix alors
d'abord un état des lieux pour commencer
un tout le monde a parlé de ça
aujourd'hui il faut bien dire les
chiffres qui parlent d'eux mêmes sur ce
succès de la droite en france
aujourd'hui ce sondage a signé harris
interactive qui confirme la dynamique
eric des mots qui atteint les 17 %
d'intentions de vote or regardez
c'est la guerre de notre génération les
auteurs des attentats terroristes ne
seront plus libérable avant 50 ans au
lieu de 30 ans aujourd'hui pour que nous
soyons certains de les mettre hors
d'état de nuire
donc 17% ce n'était pas exactement le
bon graphique on qu'on souhaitait
envoyer ce n'est pas grave celui qui
n'est toujours pas déclaré candidat et
qui n'a pas de parti qui se
qualifieraient un tel choc du jour au
second tour même si méfiance évidemment
sur les sondages ça veut dire quoi
danielle simonnet clairement la france
se droitise zemmour is alors vous avez
dit méfiant sur les sondages vous avez
raison parce que ces sondages quand même
plus de prendre en compte la moitié des
lectorats qui ne sais pas encore pour
qui le souhaitent voter et donc il ya
quand même un grand inconnu suspens
deuxièmement est ce que la france se
droitiser morize je pense que la sphère
médiatique ceux-ci mûri ça c'est
indéniable qu'une grande partie de la
sphère politique ce zemmour is parce que
finalement vous pouvez regarder
n'importe quelle chaîne d'informations
en continu depuis des semaines et des
semaines ses émaux matin midi et soir
dans tout est fait pour organiser le
phénomène et moore on sent qu'il ya une
volonté du système de à la fois
faire tomber marine le pen fait remonter
zemmour je pense qu emmanuel macron
souhaite un face à face macron zemmour
en se disant c'est comme ça qu'ils
ressentiraient est ce que la france elle
le peuple français ses émaux riche et je
t'en prie beaucoup moins sûr pourquoi
vous avez un autre sondage aujourd'hui
harris interactive qui montrent par
exemple que quatre français sur cinq est
contre finalement l'allongement du
départ à la retraite même pour l'heureux
pour le retour d'une retraite à 60 ans
au que je sache ni zemmour ni le pen ni
macro ni heller ne souhaite le retour à
la retraite à 60 ans et programme de
jean luc mélenchon et les thématiques
par exemple d'immigration et d'islam
interviennent quand
10e rang 13e rang des préoccupations des
français et des françaises dans ce
sondage où on voit que la question
sociale est beaucoup plus importante
ainsi que la question écologique
alexandre touzet madame simonet nous dit
voilà c'est ce qui c'est le système qui
fait zemmour il n'empêche on connaît
bien le fonctionnement des chaînes
d'information je ne vais pas dans le tas
parce que on a un fonctionnement à pas
mais en général on met en avant ce qui
fait de l'audience aujourd'hui
clairement il exhume ont fait tilt de
l'audience est tout simplement les
chaînes info répondent et les médias
répondent à un intérêt grandissant du
public
alors je crois qu'il ya des sujets qui
sont structurels et puis à
l'effervescence médiatique il ya une
étude du civet pauvres qui mesure qui
est infime chance de sciences po qui
mesure 2 0 à 10 comment les français se
positionnent est en fait en l'espace de
cinq ans il ya cinq points en plus chez
les français de positionnement à droite
et on le voit en europe aussi d'ailleurs
et cela touche toutes les couches de la
société parce que ça concerne aussi les
jeunes il ya effectivement une
droitisation qu'on peut constater sur
ces cinq dernières années on gagne 5
points à droite oh ça c'est un final qui
est à dire structurelles il ya des
thèmes qui effectivement
jaguère interroge la population
effectivement quand on parle des sorties
sierre des personnes qui ont été
condamnés pour faits de terrorisme avant
2015 ou la justice était moins ferme on
a un sujet devant nous on me sujet des
retours on a le sujet de la délinquance
qui augmente sensiblement d'un pays ça
ce sont des faits et puis 1 le phénomène
médiatique ou là effectivement parfois
et là je peut partager
sentiment de mon interlocutrice c'est à
dire que on aime bien faire des bulles
médiatiques à toute élection
présidentielle on est jean pierre
chevènement françois bayrou si on
remonte dans l'histoire donc
effectivement il ya un fan de bulles
médiatiques qui peut exister après je
mettrai en garde parce qu'on réfléchisse
parfois avec une histoire politique un
peu en ciel on a vu autour de nous que
ce soit en italie que ce soit aux états
unis et ce soit en angleterre
des personnages un peu hors norme
émerger donc voilà je suis partagé entre
le phénomène de bulle médiatique
et puis une tentation populiste qui peut
exister
en europe et dans les démocraties
occidentales plus largement je dirais
pas un phénomène de bulle médiatique moi
je dirais que
l'intérêt du système et d'organiser une
certaine diversion ce qui devrait faire
la une de tous les médias vraiment le
sujet d'actualité depuis le début de la
semaine notre on devrait travailler je
dirais presque un mois durant au moins
c'est le scandale dépendre des dépens d
un peppers parce que vraiment c'est le
casse c'est le casse du siècle photo m
réalisé que onze mille 300 milliards
d'euros qui partant en évasion fiscale
c'est vraiment un scandale sans commune
mesure parce que derrière il faut se
dire que c'est des hommes et des femmes
dont on hamm est donc on dont on a les
noms qui quelque part organiser la case
d'hôpitaux publics la casse des écoles
la casse de l'ensemble de nos services
publics nos politiques sociales se
faisant bon et le système n'a pas
intérêt qu'on en parle faut pas oublier
que la plupart des chaînes d'information
continue sont tenus par neuf
milliardaire ces neuf milliardaires
n'ont pas intérêt à ce que le peuple
prenne conscience de toute cette évasion
fiscale et donc on va organiser la
diversion et donc la diversion salle est
de ramener à chaque fois le sujet de
l'immigration le sujet de l'insécurité
de ramener zemmour matin midi et soir
rené moi décidons et on l'a vu votre
poulain jean luc mélenchon a un qui a
fait ce débat qui a rassemblé vache
folle affronter un adversaire et ça fait
une audience effectivement assez forte
chez nos confrères sauf que bon vous
avez bien les sondages mais oui quand
même les sondages ça n'a pas permis à
jean luc mélenchon d'émerger face à eric
zemmour qui lui a pris du galon dans les
études d'opinion vous l'expliquez
comment ça veut dire que ces sujets dont
vous me parlez eh bien ça ne suffit pas
vous dîtes le social c'est le plus
important mais il n'empêche les français
semblent s'intéresser aussi à ces
questions d'identité de
deux équipes et je rappelle quand même
le sondage harris interactive du jour
montrent que la plus grande inquiétude
des français avec occupation si le
dérèglement climatique
ensuite c'est l'avenir des enfants les
questions sociales arrive très haute la
question de l'immigration et l'islam par
exemple arrivent beaubien après bien
après donc ça c'est pour commencer
deuxièmement les sondages d'intentions
politiques montrent que jean luc
mélenchon est en progression et il est
le seul à gauche qui se démarquent
ensuite vous avez plus de 50 % des
personnes sondées qui ne sont pas sûrs
de leur vote et donc on ne prend pas en
compte dans le résultat du sondage donc
entre aujourd'hui et le jour de
l'élection les choses vont énormément
changé parce ponte on voit bien que les
sondages ont aussi un rôle à performatif
est donc là je questionne quand même
l'intérêt des médias de mètres de
présenter ces sondages sans jamais faire
une critique de ces sondages ou
d'expliquer comment sont-ils
constituer son miel type de panels et
sur quelle prise en compte des
intentions de vote alex en tout c'est ce
que vous partagez ce diagnostic de de
danielle simonnet
vous justement un titre personnel vous
expliquer comment ce succès de de la
droite parce qu'elle parle justement de
sujets cas du mal aujourd'hui à aborder
encore la gauche
je pars en est forcément ce que je
trouve que c'est parfois un peu
complotistes com com comme vision je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de médias et
quand on fait lors de chaque élection
présidentielle il y à des tests auprès
de journalistes sur leur sensibilité en
termes de candidats on a souvent des
candidats de gauche qui ressort donc on
peut pas dire que la presse en général
est détenu par des à feu droitier du cac
40 je pense que c'est un petit peu
simpliste je pense que le monde
journalistique en france est plutôt à
gauche voilà donc je pense que
le monde journalistes qui sont
propriétés des chaînes d'information
mélenchon faisait les résultats qui fait
auprès des journalistes je crois qu'il
serait président de la république donc
je pense que je m'éloigne un plus cette
manière de penser je pense que les
partis politiques prennent en compte
aussi laurel et j'en prends pour qu'on
parle de l'a3 de la droitisation de la
droite mais il ya quelques ans quelque
part aussi une droitisation de la gauche
quand j'entends il apparaît témoin sur
la thématique de l'extrême gauche par
exemple parti communiste pensent
différemment vous en matière de sécurité
on a eu des déclarations du secrétaire
général du parti communiste extrêmement
clair sur la question elle est située
été extrêmement clairs sur la question
la laïcité j'en prends pour preuve que
le dernier gouvernement hollande dont je
n'appartiens pas longer n'est pas un
soutien à évoquer la déchéance de la
nationalité a fait des lois déception en
matière de sécurité publique donc ce
n'est pas qu'un phénomène ni médiatique
mais qui concerne j'avais à dire la
droite c'est toute la gauche nous en
tout cas une partie de la gauche qui
évoluent sur cette question là moi je je
suis les questions de sécurité depuis
très longtemps je me souviens d'un temps
où les mairies de gauche pensait que les
mères qui mettait en place de la
vidéoprotection état d'extrême droite
était ddd sécuritaire affreux etc
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup gauche où
on fait de la vidéoprotection on a des
polices municipales ou en d'armes ces
polices municipales donc on voit bien
que c'est c'est pas qu'un délire de la
droite il ya aujourd'hui des parties de
des maires de gauche qui font des
actions en termes de sécurité qui font
des actions aux fins de prévention de la
délinquance qui réfléchissent au sujet
de la radicalisation
on peut pas dire que ces problèmes
n'existent pas et ils parviennent à 10
ans cia mais il ya une valorisation
sans sac
gouvernement et je pense qu'il ya des
vies aussi une vision de la société et
c'est dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle qu'on peut se permettre
ces échanges moi je voudrais réagir
c'est que là où je vais vous rejoindre
c'est qu'il ya une certaine mémorisation
aussi dans la classe politique et pas
simplement dans la sphère médiatique
juste pour la sphère médiatique entendez
ce que je dis je ne parle pas d'eux des
journalistes en termes de professions je
parle du système médiatique et donc de
qui est propriétaire des gros médias
audiovisuels et les chaînes
d'information ce n'est pas daniel minet
néfastes sur les chaînes info
morize à sion d'une salle de classe
politique je raconte emmanuel macron
décide de passer un coup de fil à eric
zemmour pour s'informer de ses positions
sur l'immigration oui c'est une
banalisation de celui qui rappelons le a
été condamné pour racisme parce que le
racisme n'est pas une opinion mais un
délit
quand il décide de diminuer de 50%
la délivrance des visas accordés aux
ressortissants du maghreb il se faisait
morize camp par contre de la même
manière quand vous avez une
manifestation des syndicats faction
d'extrême droite on faire pression sur
la justice vous avez d'ailleurs eric
zemmour qui est présent avec monsieur
darmanin et qui est présent mais vous
avez aussi madame hidalgo monsieur jadot
et monsieur roussel et bien il se
bascule dans un an là où la gauche ne
devrait jamais allé par contre lorsqu'on
a un débat une confrontation
entre jean luc mélenchon eric zemmour et
notamment on aborde la question de la
sécurité on voit que monsieur eric
zemmour n'a strictement rien à dire
parce qu'il n'a aucune réflexion poussée
j'étais de refondre il ya des sujets
regardez jean luc mélenchon pour
l'instant il n'a pas beaucoup parlé
terrorisme pour revenir à notre
chronique de tout à l'heure 37 ans d'art
mélenchon sur la question du chapitre au
sein de la chaîne big bro 5 à la vie en
iran ce travail et ces sujets là ce
qu'on attend le chapitre 500 donnez moi
on va le voir d'ailleurs regardez sur
cette infographie chapitre 5 avenir en
commun vous parlez bien de la guerre
mais mais c'est pas exactement le même
discours que la droite est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas justement s'emparer de ces
français ces sujets qui font quand même
malgré tout important centre exemple été
les seuls à dénoncer
le
la question du financement du terrorisme
par exemple moi je me souviens toujours
par exemple de ce sujet lafarge ou
lorsque le monde a révélé que lafarge
pour continuer d'exploiter une
cimenterie en syrie n'avait pas hésité à
financer des shs qu'à ce moment là les
services secrets français étaient en
lien avec lafarge pour récupérer des
informations et donc que le gouvernement
français le président de la république à
l'époque françois hollande et matheron
et aidant son équipe à l'elysée et bien
ne pouvait ignorer que nous avions là
une grande entreprise lafarge qui
finançait
d'âge et qui d'ailleurs va être
poursuivi pour complicité de crime
contre l'humanité et c'est cette
question fondamentale qui est qui
financent le terrorisme
nous sommes les seuls à la portée
ensuite oui nous avons toujours dit
qu'il faut absolument développer les
moyens humains dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
au lieu de faire une d'organiser que le
gouvernement a pu faire et bien une
ambiance dans cette société d' amalgame
et qui vise à encourager le racisme anti
musulman sans faire une distinction
entre la lutte contre le terrorisme
islamiste est par contre la lutte aussi
sur ce qu'il souhaite céder la division
de la société parce que regarder toute
cette communication qui a été faite par
le gouvernement sur la question ce
concept inventé du séparatisme n'a aucun
impact dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme aucun la seule chose qu'il a
pour ré résultat c'est la banalisation
du racisme et on voit bien que
l'objectif des terroristes qui est
d'organiser la division de la société et
bien et l'autre face de l'objectif de
l'extrême droite et il se retrouve
alexandre touzet je voudrais justement
vous montrer avant de répondre à
danielle simonnet les propositions que
l'un de vos poulains pas encore
officiellement xavier bertrand par
exemple font sur ces questions de
terrorisme au regard des
c'est la guerre de notre génération les
auteurs des attentats terroristes ne
seront plus libérable avant 50 ans au
lieu de 30 ans aujourd'hui pour que nous
soyons certains de les mettre hors
d'état de nuire pour vous aviez bertrand
ça suffit là le bon diagnostic les
bonnes réponses sur ces questions là
j'aurais peut-être revenir et on voit
bien les lignes de partage des revenus
par 13 qui existe au sein même de la
gauche je pense pas que quand on
manifeste avec des policiers ont soit
contre la république je sais quelques
jours qu'elle soit 100
% de la population
qui apprécient sa police et sa
gendarmerie oui et je pense que
manifester aux côtés de sa police et
gendarmerie c'est tout à fait normal
c'est elle c'est tout l'art de
manifester aux côtés du ccf enfin voilà
c'est ma façon de penser
avec des policiers des gendarmes qu'avec
des islamo gauchiste je trouve ça plus
honorable et plus en lien avec la
république oui la manifestation que ccf
ont crié allah ouakbar dans la
manifestation n'était mois sont partis
politiques d'extrême gauche se sont
fourvoyés quant à la question
de effectivement je soutient aucun
candidat dans mon camp j'ai décidé pour
l'instant d'écouté et éventuellement
prendre position dernièrement mais je
pense que effectivement la question des
retours de zone la question des sorties
de prison sert à la fois des personnes
qui ont été condamnés à des courtes
peines puisque avant 2015 avant les
attentats majeurs de 2015 les peines
étaient plus légère la question la
radicalisation en prison des droits
communs la question est effectivement
d'un certain nombre de français qui ne
sont pas qu'ils sont cons free avec la
république ces sujets là sont des sujets
majeurs
j'ai travaillé notamment le cas des
départements de france à la question la
radicalisation interne y compris dans
les services publics on a des vrais des
sujets majeurs qu'il faut traiter et de
et surtout qu'on sorte de ce faux
concept d'islamophobie qui est un
concept qui est un concept frériste en
fait qui souhaite opposer les musulmans
de france à l'état la république en
disant qu'ils sont persécutés en france
et musulmans ne sont pas persécutés en
france il n'y a personne ne persécute et
en france on est dans une république où
chacun peut vivre et qu'on arrête de
faire croire aux musulmans que ce sont
les damnés de la terre que c'est le
prolétariat du 21e siècle d'accord c'est
une clientèle et orale vous mais je
pense qu'il faut arrêter de route de
remonter les musulmans contre la
république c'est une grave erreur et
c'est ce que les frères musulmans
souhaitent absolument et vous tombez
dans le panneau de façon naïve et
déconcertante de faire remonter les
musulmans contrat république la
république est ouverte il ya aucun
problème par rapport à ça mais
effectivement il faut lutter contre
l'islam politique et moi j'assume de
métier contre l'islam politique je gère
pas une clientèle électorale merci je
suis désolé on arrive à la fin danielle
simonnet répondre à la prochaine fois
sur un prochain débat merci en tout cas
à vous de alexandre touzet 27